okay so in this presentation we're going
to discuss community interactions that
exist within the ecological world so
let's go ahead and get started
so let's remind ourselves what a
community is it's all the living species
within a given area all the reptiles and
insects and plants would make up the
community of this particular desert all
the life you could find in this African
savanna makes up this community all the
invertebrates all the fish all the
corals would make up the life in this
community so how does life interact with
one another well like these two Rams
butting heads with one another they're
probably competing for territory another
form of interaction would be predator
and prey one organism simply eats
another and then the third type of
community interaction would be the
various kinds of symbiosis so these are
going to be the subjects of our video
today
so let's go ahead and talk about
competition you know in a community
there are factors that will limit the
size of a population we call these
limiting factors you know examples would
be like habitats there's only so many
places to live in a community another
example of a limiting factor would be
water you know there's only so many
elephants that can survive off of the
water in Africa another great example of
a limiting factor is territory you know
we have a couple male Rams butting heads
with one another to win territory and in
that territory are food and water and
inmates so competition occurs whenever
there is a challenge for these resources
whenever the resources are limited
organisms within the community tend to
compete with one another you know kind
of another fun territorial example is
the Battle of territory between male
elephant seals you know maybe the
elephant seal here on the left is the
current champion the beachmaster
and the beachmaster owns all the
resources on the beach that would
include females to mate with and every
now and then a young challenger will
step up to the beachmaster and they will
fight for the right to claim their
territory these are you know a great
example here of of an example of
competition for limited resources
you know I briefly want to discuss a
fairly famous experiment that was done
on the topic of competition between
microscopic organisms known as paramecia
which tend to live in freshwater ponds
and rivers and lakes and there's a few
species of paramecia that were examined
within this particular experiment one of
them is called P irelia the P stands for
paramecia and this paramecia was grown
in a lab condition in a lab setting all
by itself without any other species to
compete with and over the time if we
start plotting the population size over
the time as the paramecia was given
nutrients it grew and multiplied and as
time went by grew and multiplied even
further and as more time passed it
multiplied and again it was given a
steady amount of nutrition and as you
can see eventually the population
started to level off because again food
even though the paramecia was given food
food is a limiting factor which led to
the paramecia kind of hitting a plateau
and leveling off well look at the next
part of this experiment
so in the next part of this experiment a
different species of paramecia called
Pequod Adam P stands for paramecia was
grown again in a lab similar settings
where it was given food and the parent
the population started out very small
but over time because it was given ample
food the Paramecium multiplied and as
time went by the Paramecium multiplied
even further and as time went by the
paramecia even multiplied even further
and eventually like we saw a moment to
go with the other paramecia there was a
leveling off period where you know
resources became a little little limited
and so the population kind of flatlined
and leveled off well now look what
happened in this experiment
so then in the experiment the researcher
grew both paramecia together and they
fed off of the same nutrients and what
happened is a good example of why we're
talking about this in our notes today in
red the p-card atom and in blue the pr
elia their population began very small
and then as time passed as time passed
the in red the p-card atom multiplied a
little bit and in blue the pea irelia
multiplied a little bit as well as more
time passed the p-card Otteman red
multiplied as more time passed the pea
irelia in blue multiplied but they
multiplied it a little higher rate well
now look what happened over time the pea
irelia was just more successful at
capturing food and so it was multiplying
and out competing in red the Pequod's
atom the p-card atom actually started to
die off because they just weren't able
to feed as well and were being out
competed for the limited nutrients that
were provided to both of the paramecia
when they were mixed together and as
time passed in in blue the paramecia
kadhai a paramecia irelia continued to
thrive and eventually they started to
flatten off because again food was
becoming real scarce for all and as time
went by in red the paramecium caudatum
was really struggling to survive they
were just being out competed and in blue
we see again the paramecia irelia hits a
flattening off period and in red the
paramecia cod atom eventually died off
and so when we make our line graph we
can see that when they had to compete
one usually out competed the other this
led to what is known as the competitive
exclusion principle so the competitive
exclusion principle says that no two
species can occupy the same niche or the
same role in the environment at the same
time with another that also occupies the
same niche they will compete in that
competition will usually exclude one
and allow the other to continue to
survive well we see this in the world of
business as well think about what
happens what tends to happen to the
private locally owned hardware store
when maybe a few blocks down the road a
hardware super super store opens nearby
chances are the super store can offer
lower prices than the locally owned
hardware store and that's probably gonna
sadly go out of business you know we see
this in other areas of business as well
you know major coffee coffee chains have
put a lot of small privately owned
coffee businesses out of business
you know also we see super stores like
Walmart when they tend to move into an
area small privately owned stores tend
to go out of business because they can't
compete with the lower prices so we see
this in nature and in economics as well
okay shifting back to community
interactions let's quickly discuss
predation you know this is pretty
straightforward I think when one
organism captures and feeds on another
organism one organism is the predator
one organism is the prey or the victim
and so the predator would be the hunter
and the prey would be the hunted and in
this case a fox has killed maybe a
prairie dog I can't really tell what
that is in the picture but that would be
its prey and we see this in you know
food chains one organism will be eaten
by the next organism up on the food
chain and that organism is eaten by the
next organism up on the food chain and
and we see how life interacts with with
the organism below it in the food chain
and as we remind ourselves within a
community food webs can be very complex
because they tend to show all the
feeding interactions between all the
members within a community
so the feeding and the the feeding
relationships within a community can be
quite complex and these are often
symbolized in what are called food webs
if we now shift focus to symbiosis
symbiosis is a relationship where two
species will live in a closely knit
relationship now sometimes both benefit
from this relationship but not always
what we're going to talk about are the
three types of symbiosis mutualism where
both individuals tend to benefit
commensalism where one benefits and the
other really receives nothing from the
relationship and then parasitism where
one benefits and the other is harmed so
let's go through mutualism first
so if we start with mutualism this is a
relationship where both species involved
benefit from one from living in a close
relationship with one another classic
example would be that of the clownfish
and the anemone the clownfish will live
and hide amongst the tentacles of the
anemones so the clownfish gains a home
the anemone will be cleaned by the
clownfish the anemone will feed off of
waste from the clownfish and the
clownfish will actually scare away
predators that might attack the anemone
and so they both benefit another kind of
fun example is that of cleaner organisms
you know the red-billed oxpecker is just
one example of a cleaner animal and what
this animal does the the oxpecker is
that it will eat parasites off of the
bodies of the second organism involved
in this picture it tends to be a buffalo
so the buffalo benefits by being free of
parasites and the bird receives a meal
there's all kinds of examples of cleaner
organisms there are fish small fish that
will clean the mouths of bigger fish
birds that will clean the mouths of
crocodiles shrimp that will clean off
and eat parasites off of for instance
crabs and and other ocean life another
classic example is the relationship
between hummingbirds which will feed on
the nectar and flowers which will
receive pollination they both benefit
the hummingbird receives food and the
flower is able to reproduce because the
hummingbird will transfer pollen from
flower to flower to flower as it flies
around
let's shift focus to commensalism in
this relationship one member will
benefit and the other isn't either
helped nor harmed you know a good
example is this picture right here
notice the small white birds in the
picture these are called egrets and they
will live in a close relationship with
for instance horses and cattle pigs as
the horses and the cattles and the pigs
you know roam around they stomp around
they stir up insects which are then fed
upon by the Egret so the Egret benefits
by getting food and there doesn't really
seem to be any benefit to the horses or
the cattle that are stomping around
stirring up the insects another good
example of commensalism is for instance
in barnacles now here's a picture of a
whale coming to the surface you see its
blowhole there at the top of the picture
and in this picture you can see there
are barnacles that have attached
themselves to the outside of the whale
and the barnacles benefit number one
they have a home free from predators
because not really much hunts these
whales and also the barnacles have
better access to food because the whales
are swimming through the water which you
know is how barnacles get their food
barnacles will just filter food out of
the water and as the whales swim through
there the water of the ocean the
barnacles will filter and feed out
organisms for them to live off of so a
great example where the barnacle
benefits and as far as we can tell there
doesn't seem to be any harm done to the
whales another example of commensalism
is epiphytes epiphytes are plants that
live on top of other plants you know
here's a picture of an epiphyte you know
dozens and dozens and dozens of feet off
the ground living amongst the treetops
of another species a plant this at the
fight benefits because it has better
access to sunlight and there you know
it's not a parasitic relationship
there's no harm being done to the tree
that it's living on top of
and so the last example is parasitism
this is where one organism benefits and
the other is harmed and probably the
classic example of parasitism is that of
a tapeworm and so humans can be infected
by with a tapeworm by eating infected or
undercooked meat and then the tapeworm
larvae will begin to grow inside of our
intestines and the tapeworm when we look
at the head of a tapeworm it's got these
hooks on it and these hooks will hook
onto our intestines and and so they feed
on food that passes through our
intestines and ultimately if we look in
the pinkish area of this of this chart
here these are some of the side effects
that tend to come from you know having
for instance parasites living in us for
instance ones for instance the parasite
of a tapeworm these are some of the side
effects that we that we tend to see in
humans let's that forget tapeworms are
not the only examples of parasites you
know fleas and ticks well feed off of
the blood of our pets and of course not
just our pets but for you pet owners out
there again you know flea and tick
season make sure you guys you know are
checking your dog and taking care of
man's best friend
so as I wrap up this video I want to
leave you with not just the practice
quiz but also kind of what I consider to
be a funny example of commensalism so if
you read over this example and actually
look on YouTube for videos of this it's
pretty hilarious I think so go ahead and
you know try this practice quiz and if
you're in my class I'm happy to check
your answers before school or after
school one day thanks for watching